[音楽]
みなさんこんにちは
影響は皆さんに見せたいものがあって一つ持ってきたものがあります
吊らこのコンパスです
今日はこのあんまりくる時にこのコンパスを使ってどっちだろうどっちらを追ってきて
いました
で普段もうクラスコンパスつかなくてスマホを使っています
スマホがあれば今世界中どこにいても自分の居場所がわかり
好きな場所に行くことができます
ただ目的を決めるのはスマホではなくて
ここ心のコンパス好奇心です
僕は3年前まで2年半をかけて世界使用してました
アイスランドという国に行き地球の美しさに驚き
気
見えてあげるマグマを見て
地球の強さにを届きました
そしてアフリカに行って民族と出会いいい
文化の違いに触れこれまで103の国々を旅してきました
そして最近では南極に行ってました
ペンギン読み切ったわけじゃなくてここでマラソンをしてました
マラソンが終わって音声があるよと言われて連れて行かれたのが
な曲のみでしたあ
で本当に詰めなくてここエジルかと思いました
もう一生ありません
デイ最近1か月前はキックボクシングにも挑戦しました
体重が10%を切る歩道も焼いて対戦しなんとか勝ちましたが頭がめちゃくちゃ痛かっ
たです
こんなことに挑戦しているとよくみんなにそのエネルギーはどこから来るの
と言われます
それは幸せを探すのが好きだからです
僕は小さい頃しあわせって何だろうなんて考えたこともなかったけど
大人になるにつれて幸せて何だろうと考えてみました
誰かが言う幸せをかけたり誰かの女あ
誰かの言葉を気にしてやりたいことにチャレンジできずに言いました
そんな僕にも夢はありました
小学校からサッカーを続けずっとプロサッカー選手になると思って生きていました
だけど高校に入りサッカー部に入りませんでした
父親から高校に入ったらレギュラーになれるか分からないと言われ
僕もプロサッカー選手になれなかったらどうしようと不安になり
言い訳をつくって夢から逃げました
高校では勉強頑張っていました
有名大学に行こうと思って努力していたけど
どの学部に行っていいかわからず
本当にやりたいことは何だろうそう思ったらサッカーしかありませんでした
なんでサッカーを辞めてしまったんだ僕はずっと後悔して毎日泣いてました
それからもう一度サッカーに変わりたいスポーツに変わりたいと思い
スポーツ学科のある大学に入学しました
大学ではスポーツを学びサッカーを教えたりしていたけど
自分がプレーしてしていた時ほどワクワクせず
だんだんとサッカーからも離れていきました
そして次は就職です
どんな企業に就職したらいいんだろう
有名な企業
それとも給料がいいところ
収束したら
昇進して不調になって
いい給料もらって結婚して子供が産まれて老後を過ごしていく
そう考えたら僕の人生が自分のものじゃないみたいでした
生きるって何だろう
それがわからず僕は大学の図書館に行きいける3そんな本を読んでみたり
生きる意味が分からないから今度は死ぬみっていう本を読んでみました
その時本当に悩んでいてお風呂に入って頭を洗うと髪の毛で真っ黒になってました
1日髪の毛何本を抜けるかを調べて100本に200本抜けるって言うことを知って
春季かと思いました
でも本当に悩んでいて
その正解がわからずもうやりたいことをやるしかないんだと思い僕はやりたいことを
ノートに書き出しました
綺麗な海が見たい世界中に友達を作りたい英語を話したい
もっと自分が知っ輝きたい
それを見た時に留学だと思いました
でもアメリカやイギリスじゃなくてもっともっと知らない世界に行きたいそう思って僕
は南の島フィジーに行くことを決めました
フィジーは四国ほどの大きさです
とびっきり綺麗なこんな青い海が広がっていて
世界にはこんな綺麗な実があるんだと思うか驚きました
そして肘が世界一幸せな国と言われています
あなたは幸せですかと聞いた時に入って答える人が世界で一番多いと言われています
ちなみにフィジーはこんな人です
これは交通整備をしている人なんですけどめちゃくちゃ楽しそうじゃないですか
ハイビスカスをつけて踊りながら仕事をしていて疲れたら後ろにあるコーラを飲んでい
ました
この時に僕は仕事って辛くて大変なものだと思ったんですよ
だけどこれを見て仕事って楽しんでいいんだって初めて思いました
フィジーには経歴でという文化があります
お前の物は俺の物でも俺のものもお前のものちょっと優しいジャイアンみたいです
僕がホームステイしているときのこと t シャツがなくなってどこなって探している
と子どもが外できていたり
バーでお酒を飲んでたら知らない人が僕の酒を飲んだりしました
もし一番驚いたのがバスを待っている時のことです
僕がバスを持ち待っていて隣にしあの友達の美人がいてその後ろに知らないフィ人がい
ました
バスが来て僕が乗ってお金を払って友達もお金を払いました
知らない身近なとフィ人が乗ったときに僕お金ないんですって言ったんです
じゃなんで並んでたのと思いませんそしたら友達のフィ人が払ってあげたんです
何でお金払ったのって聞いたら僕お金あるからと言いましたでも彼全然お金持ちじゃ
ないんです
じゃあお金なくなったらどうするのって聞いたら
誰かが払ってくれるから大丈夫その時はって言いました
それで家族だったらありえるけど知らない人同士でありえるって凄くないですか
僕はフィジーが国全体が家族のように感じました
僕たち先進国が
発展してきたことでそぎ落としてしまった何か大切な温かいものがフィジに歩き出し
ました
そして僕はもっともっと世界を見て自分の幸せを見つけたいと新しい夢が出来ました
大学卒業してから僕は3年間日本で働きました
稼ぐって何だろうお金って何だろう仕事って何だろう
僕は一度稼いでみようと不動産会社に就職しました
1年目は会社ででもビリでした全然お金がなくて
月末は数百円しかなくて
毎日牛丼を食べてでもお味噌汁が飲みたいから
松屋しか行けませんでした
そして2年目になりへ急に成績が一番なりました
そして月収が南東約200万円ぐらいなりました
お金を稼いでいて銀座で働いていてなんかかっこいい感じはする
安定した生活も送れるかもしれない
だけど死ぬ時に何をしなかったら後悔するんだろう
そう思った時に僕が思ったのは世界集でした
もうサッカーをやめたときのような後悔したくなかったんです
社会的にかっこいい自分じゃなくて理想的な自分を生きたい
26歳にして僕は初めて誰かが入ったいいではなく自分の好きを選ぶことができました
仕事を辞めて僕は自分の価値を自分で作っていくと世界中で挑戦してきました
世界に出るからには世界一を味わいたいと思い僕は世界一過酷なサハラマラソンに参加
しました
このサハラマラソンなんですが最高金は55度です
そして距離はなんと250キロです
僕は世界一過酷なマラソンに世界一過酷な状況じゃないと思い練習ゼロで荷物15キロ
背負って参加しました
でもみんなは1グラムでも荷物を減らそうと努力してくるんですよ
例えばこの人歯ブラシは先端しか持ってこないです
僕は歯ブラシ1本持ってきてるし歯磨き粉を持ってきてるし
重い荷物背負ってました
なによりきつかったのが小さめの靴を履いてしまったことでした
3日目になるとも足がパンパンで靴から足が出るんじゃないかぐらい痛かったです
そして僕の隣の人なんてこんな4でした
足の爪が全部取れて足の皮めくれていました
でもこの人乾燥するんです
腹砂漠は
自閉性を何度超えてもチェーン戦しかありませんでした
250キロ先のボールなで全然見えませんでした
4日目5日目になると足が棒のようでした
その時に僕ができたことは1ミリでも進むこと
一方でも進むことでしたそれだけを意識して進んでいました
そしたらなんとオールできたんです
しかも世界二位でした
下から数えたですが
そんな僕も学んだことがあります
それはどんなに頭夢だったりゴールでも
今日1ミリでも一方でも住んでたら絶対にゴールに近づいてるってことです
僕はそれを学ぶことができました
そしてサハラマラソンを終えた後に1週間後ドイツに行きました
さあドイツでフルマラソンがあったんですよでその日に参加できるって聞いて僕は参加
しました
その時はすごく面白くてスタートしてあるじゃないですか
そこにこう立った瞬間にもうすぐゴールだって思ったんです
サハラマラソンの最終みたいだし荷物背負わなくていいし
食料や水とかをその辺でくれるしこれ一瞬ちゃんって
高そう思ったときに自分が挑戦していくと常識とか限界の幅がどんどん広がっていって
世界が面白くなってきました
だけど旅していると度がにしようにもなってきます
観光地に行くのが当たり前だし美味しい食べ物は一度も食べれるし
僕は一番感動したことはやっぱりサハラマラソンを走り終えた時なんです
よし一番美味しかったものはサハラマラソンを走り終えた時のコーラでした
この時に僕が思ったのは
会えるのは旅の行き先じゃなくて自分の生き方だと思いました
自分のに資料を同劇場にできるか
僕はそこからまた旅を続けました
そしてキルギスという国に行った時に路盤が買えるって噂を聞いてそれめっちゃのマン
ちゃんと思ったんですよ
ロバート旅したいインターネットでロバの飼い方って調べても出てこなくて旅した人が
いなくて
じゃあもうロバを買いたいってキルギス語で書いて応募過疎旅行待って
村に行きました
その時の動画があります
これは吉恵民村という村に行ったときですこの時に初めてロボットとやりました
ん
僕が買ったロバで名前はミミちゃんです
みみちゃんに鞍を着けて荷物を載せて
冒険スタートします
めちゃくちゃ冒険ぽくないですか
ん
でこれがミミちゃんなんですけどこれいくらで買ったと思います
最初これ10万円って言われたんですよでもた人の僕は10万円ってか偉いなぁと思っ
て
お願いもうちょっと安くしてと言ったらなんと9000円で買いました
安すぎじゃないですかでこの意味ちゃ
なにより良いのがめちゃくちゃ笑顔なんです
僕はもう最高のパートナーを見つけると思いました
でそれでサハラマラソンも走っているし
を僕はどこまでも行けると思ったので500キロ先の山の上をゴールにしました
そしてスタートして
産地が経ちました
3時間経って進んだ距離がなんとたったの50メートルだったんです
全然進んでなくてみーちゃんがもうこんな状態になってしまいました
でこのままだとヤバいと思って先に耳茶より自分が餓死すると思って村に戻って水を
買いに行きました
さあ村人に今日うちでごはん食べていきなよって言われて
分かったあでもみみちゃんいるからちょっとズレてくる熱ってミミちゃんとかも撮った
んですよ
したのみみたい逃げられてて期間に保つことはなかったんです
でこれやばいなと思ってその日も探して次の日も探してもいなくて
僕は少しのお金とパスポートしか持ってなかったんです
ずっと村長迷っていると
急におばあちゃんに来い来い来いと言われていえなかにドーンと言われました
そこは六畳一間ぐらいの大きさの家で
そこには7人の娘息子がいました
いきなりお前が今日からこの長男だと言われて僕はそこに10日間住み始めました
ジャスミンと一緒に朝水を汲みに行ったりいるは邪推っと一緒にトウモロコシを買っ
たり夜はお母さんと一緒にパンを作ってみました
まるで本当の家族のように可愛がってくれましたん
この時に僕はこれが本当にの旅なんだなーって思ったんです
やりたいことがあったらそこに道がなくても自分で道をつくっていく
それができたら世界中どこにいても自分らしい旅ができるんだと思いました
僕は今幸せです
そしてもっともっと幸せを探していきたいと思っています
そしていろんな人と一緒に幸せを味わいたいと思っています
今僕は世界集学校というコミュニティを作っていて
キャンピングカーで日本もあったり
チェックボクシングやフットサルの部活をつくったり一緒に世界中旅に行っています
学校卒業してからもこうやっていろんな仲間と一緒に挑戦して楽しむことができて僕は
すごく幸せです
これ最後に
幸せを探す上で大切だと思っていることをお伝えします
それは好奇心というコンパスを壊さないでください
公金のコンパスが壊れると何をしていいかわからなくなります
誰かの常識やルールがないと人生を選べなくなってしまいます
僕は昔言われました
海外に行ったから成功するわけじゃない
だけどそこに一歩を踏み出してみると
新しい出会いがあったり
応援してくれる人がいたり
支えてくれている人がいたり
一緒に一緒に挑戦してくれる人がいたり
幸せがどんどん増えてきました
海外に行ってみたい
たった一つの小さな好奇心が
僕を世界中に連れてってくれました
だから皆さんも好奇心のコンパスを真実みてください
なんかいいなぁとかなんか好きだなーとか
そういったものがあったらやってみてください
そして心が楽しいとかうれしいとか感じたらそれを大切にしてください
そしたら
少しずつやりたいことが見つかってくると思います
そしてやりたいことをやりとけ
自分との約束を果たして言ったらそれが自信になります
もし
夢をあきらめて後悔してる人がいたら
やりたいことがあってまだできていない人がいたらぜひ一歩踏み出してみてください
きっと誰もが想像したこともない
正解があります
人生はいつも今がスタート地点です
ありがとうございました
[拍手]